i
i i'm not i'm so happy that the kids
were out here because mike and i had a
16-foot
open whaler we had no place to put any
victims
we were a two-man team we simply asked
him to back off
there was some unnecessary conversation
that happened mike eventually
asked if we could tie off to the back of
their boat
they led us they said what did the young
fella say
go ahead or thanks yeah have at it have
at it and i'm pretty sure
that that young fella name is
mike rosalet i think and i think he also
was mentioned in a book
not too long ago uh and so that's uh
kind of like where i got his name and
stuff
but they were that the kids were
fantastic kids what specifically were
the kids
doing the kids when we first got there
they were kind of scattered at the
surface
were they in the water yeah they had no
you know
the skyway isn't a place to go to learn
how to dive or to be
right for your first couple of dives i
don't think they were prepared for the
current and the velocity
let alone the commotion in the water and
stuff going the other activities the
boats and
people buzzing around several of them
were bobbing
at the surface drifting away from the
boat i could tell that they were
not going to be or be around apparently
a couple of the kids
did enter the water and
go around the boat the bus i'm sorry
and i was kind of disturbed i believe i
read in the
times or the evening independent that
one of the divers
indicated that he went around to the
back of the bus now remember as far as
i'm concerned when we first got there
this is an accident investigation scene
okay state representatives we identified
ourselves they knew who we were
that's what we were doing investigating
an accident
i had read in the paper that one of
those divers from the
eckerd rescue team went to the back of
that bus and opened up the door
and saw a massive bodies and left them
there
or couldn't get them out that's okay
you know that's tough but didn't
make an attempt to close the door so
that kind of like bothered me a little
bit i mean i i we appreciate the help
and stuff but they actually were
disturbing the scene
i didn't think that that needed to be
done and i and i wish that somebody
would have told us back then
that was that that had occurred i'd have
gone back down and closed that door
do you think maybe they originally
thought maybe they just had good
intentions like you said
absolutely i'm sure there could have
been some potential circumstances
absolutely
i'm sure they did and and that's why i
say i'm not mad at the kids i just wish
if we could have communicated and
someone that you would have said i left
the door open
maybe that you know i'd have jumped back
in and closed it was there any
possibility of any survivors when you
got there did you
when you guys got there what was the
feeling did you think there could be
some survivors or do you think that it
was just
it was that was a tough call uh at that
specific time we we really didn't know
what we did notice was that the back of
the bus was still
relatively afloat it was held up mostly
by the dual wheels in the back
early pictures of that will show that
the bus was at a severe
at a pretty good angle with the back
wheels up so there must have been some
air in there
to the best of my knowledge and i
haven't found anybody tell me anything
different
i was the first and the only person to
go on that bus
i had hoped beyond all hope that i would
unfortunately i was not able to find
anybody
that was alive or even looked like they
had been
i believe the coroner's report on the 35
victims
were 28 individuals
perished from severe trauma impact
and that seven people had drowned
which would have meant that they it
survived the crash but
drowned that was the hillsborough county
coroner's report i believe that was the
final count
so it was possible unfortunately for us
it didn't work out that way
[Music]
so the bus was the back of the bus was
kind of
near the surface and then when you guys
got there
you decided that you needed to get in
the water
and get inside the bus and try to what
was your plan
after we tied off after we asked them
we asked them to please just get back in
the boat and help us
recover the victims receive the victims
and take care of them because
like they we had 16-foot boston wheeler
there was no way we could do that
we we suited up we rolled over
we were in the water for less than
10-15 minutes when we came up to the bus
it was upside down it was facing south
i observed the bus driver
my curt my curtis he was still behind
the wheel
he was inverted i
had my by my side he was with me
flip or stroke for flipper stroke you
guys were done the whole time
side by side visibility was very good
about 30 feet
wow the front of the bus was anywhere
between 10 and 15 feet below the surface
of the water
after the bubbles cleared we rolled in
we could see the bus inverted i could
see mr curtin upside down
i headed to the front of the bus i
positioned mike i asked mike
to stay outside didn't think there would
be
any need for two of us plus i obviously
felt it was my responsibility as a
senior man to take that responsibility
which i did
i positioned mike outside the window
near what would have been the
entrance door
handed mr curtis to to mike uh
went in a little bit further and
recovered another victim
and passed him out for mike so mike was
outside
with two victims i i went back
in a little bit further i i didn't
realize how far
uh i was going in the bus because i
wasn't concentrating on that i didn't
realize
until recently mike and i really haven't
talked about that
until recently when mike told me that
a couple of times that when i went in
the bus that he couldn't see me
which to me meant that i went in a
little bit further than i thought
in a documentary they mentioned that the
roof had been like sheared off yes it
had
yes it has the pictures are available on
plenty of places that had been just
about where the seats were
where the hard portion ends and the
windows are
was completely sheared if it was upside
down it would probably be less than
less than four feet of crawl space yeah
it was a mangled mist
is what i crawled into so were you
actually
in the aisle you were in in the aisle
but were you surrounded by
bus structure or was there like nothing
below you had
we had the floor the chassis was
overhead yeah chassis and the walls
and the seats going down okay and then
below you was what
the steel structure of the bridge it
landed on top of the bridge
the truss it tumbled on top of the
bridge
i went in and grabbed two more victims
uh disconnected them from the seat
uh seat belts you under the seat belts
no they didn't have any seat belts
oh okay oh yeah yeah greyhound uh i i i
i wanna i wanna say this to all the uh
family members and stuff is that
it was
very difficult to
extract many of those people
however i did the best i could
and treated them with as much respect
as i could at the time
i said a soft prayer
for each one
that i recovered and apologized
for the treatment that i was given them
at the time
but i did feel it was necessary to get
them out of there as fast as we can
because i understood that everybody
needed closure
and so did we we did everything we could
to be as respectful as we could
when i came out with the second set of
victims
mike and i headed up to the surface and
handed them
to the kids that were waiting on the
back of the swim platforms
of the boat
first victim was mike curtin
and he was a good size man he was over
six foot tall
i remember his engineer boots his white
shirt he was arrested
resting on the back of the swim platform
got a picture of him here yeah can you
hold it up
it's a little bit a little like the same
height as your head right there yeah
perfect
yep my curtain right here
this is this is mike
this is me these are some of the victims
that we brought up
kids from eckerd college it's about
eight or nine kids
where was that photo taken from i'm not
real sure because i was busy at the time
but i'm pretty sure it was taken from up
top
yeah on the second bridge whatever was
left of the bridge right
that picture was a portion of
i guess a film because it was featured
in the documentary
okay so it's there uh and this second
documentary was colorized
and i had never seen that before and i
tell you when i saw it recently it
struck home it was yeah pretty hard
so we had arrived at the surface
we transp we passed the bodies off the
the victims off they seemed to struggle
a little bit but i think it was because
they
they were overwhelmed i don't think they
had any idea when they got up
and were rustled up there in the morning
that they were prepared for that i don't
think they had ever seen anything
very few of us were i had either
mikey i had combat experience so i had
dealt with that i had yeah
been through some of that stuff but even
even then at that time
and it was only going to get worse i
later realized you know that that we
were just trying to get everybody out
and
and organize and get them out of there
as fast i can
they they seem to have a difficult time
so
we had an opportunity to get back into
our boat as they were
putting people in into the recovery
boats
uh got a call from our supervisor who
wanted to come down
so he climbed down on the access ladder
from 150 feet by himself
and came to the northbound main span
and dropped the last two three feet
two or three feet into the boat and the
16 foot open whaler
and he drove our boat back out to that
location
we re-anchored off the back of the
eckerd college boat so now we had three
people in the boat
including our supervisor
they look like they were getting a
handle on the victims and and there was
more room in the back
a couple of divers had popped up
i think these were that might have been
one of the volunteers and then i think
there's a
saint pete fire department volunteer
diver who came by
i think he helped also they uh had done
some diving down at the
at the bottom of the bay
right we uh
after the supervisor got in there tied
back off
and we rolled back in for a second trip
into the bus
station mike out front again
and uh because i had removed some of the
people from
near the front of the bus obviously i
had to go in a little bit further the
second time
it was basically the same procedure i
was able to
only extricate three people at this time
with what i had uh i
brought two of them out and gave them to
mike
that's when for me uh things got uh
a little more intense